ces échanges il ventait sq deux êtres au
démarrage d'une chaîne grandi en même
temps qu'on voit grandir la chaîne dans
laquelle on est je pense qu'on a
beaucoup de chance d'avoir vécu ça pour
être très honnête quand je suis arrivé
et le cp j'ai dit à mon meilleur ami
juge dans une semaine je suis parti hu à
25 ans je réalisais pas du tout où
j'étais et je m'étais dit que j'allais
rester un an et elle sait plus vingt ans
plus tard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'arlésienne était une belle femme dont
on parlait toujours et qu'on ne voyait
jamais nous avons failli frisé la belle
image de l'arlésienne mais nous voilà
sauvés la chaîne parlementaire va
exister si nous la voterons sera t-elle
belle et m parlera-t-on l'ordre du jour
appelle de la proposition de loi portant
création de la chaîne parlementaire
le 16 décembre 1999 sur une proposition
de loi déposée par le président de
l'assemblée nationale laurent fabius
les députés discutent d'un projet
ambitieux la création d'une chaîne de
télévision dévolu à l'activité
parlementaire
autrement dit la mise en place d'un
média grand public pour raviver le lien
démocratique et redorer l'image de la
politique
j'ai été deux fois président de
l'assemblée je crois que la première
fois que j'ai eu ce souhait c'est lors
de ma première présidence c'est à dire à
la fin des années 80 à cette époque les
téléspectateurs français connaissent
déjà bien l'hémicycle depuis fin 1981 il
peut voir à l'heure de la sieste et
plusieurs fois par semaine les séances
de questions au gouvernement
retransmises en direct sur fr3 mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs bonjour
bienvenue à l'assemblée nationale pour
la première séance de retransmission en
direct sur l'a320 côté positif c'est
qu'on voyait les échanges parlementaires
mais le côté négatif c'est que c'est un
peu le cirque choisissons nous
choisissons choisissant et chers
collègues
monsieur blanc site
très chers collègues je ne suis pas sûr
que le spectacle qui est ainsi donnée
soit le meilleur
monsieur blanc on peut tout avoir des
convictions elle est exprimée avec calme
était désolé que l'image que le grand
public avait des parlementaires c'était
uniquement les séances de questions
d'actualité qui on voyait l'un qu'ils
grattent elle née l'autriche a lutté et
ses ailes parlement c'est autre chose
quand même et donc l'image de ce qui se
passe dans le pays je me suis dit faut
absolument qu'on crée un moyen de
diffusion beaucoup plus large
après il fallait savoir si on faisait
une chaîne parlementaire avec les deux
chambres l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat
ou si on en faisait deux moitiés ça ça a
été la première bataille est donc les
sénateurs voulaient leur chaîne e et les
députés voulaient leur chaîne à e
donc on a coupé le la pomme en deux une
moitié de pommes pour le sénat et
l'autre moitié pour l'assemblée
nationale
à défaut de parvenir à créer une chaîne
commune les deux chambres s'accordent
donc pour en partager une en alternance
c'était compliqué à faire autrement
d'abord parce que sinon ça aurait coûté
très cher en plus les fréquences
il n'y a pas tellement à l'époque a
attribué il y avait beaucoup de
résistances au sein même de l'assemblée
j'aurais dire d'abord
l'admiration que j'ai pour mes collègues
de l'opposition qui étaient pour la
chaîne parlementaire la semaine dernière
qui sont contre cette semaine
l'opposition de l'époque mais c'était
plus lâches que l'opposition croyez que
cela est une machine de guerre pour que
la majorité de l'époque puisse dominer
l'opposition vous pouvez passer en force
vous avez la majorité vous pouvez faire
votre 2 michel
comment éviter de faire télé fabius ici
et et les ponceaux les là bas il y avait
aussi l'idée à l'époque maintenant je
pense que c'est terminé que les deux
assemblées se regardent en chiens de
faïence il se trouvait que je vais des
relations amicales avec le président du
sénat de l'époque qui s'appelait
christian poncelet et donc qu'on a
surmonté ensemble cette difficulté qui
avant avait tout bloqué le 30 décembre
1999 la loi portant création de la
chaîne parlementaire et voter d'autant
le palais bourbon d'un outil résolument
moderne pour entrer dans le troisième
millénaire
à partir de là tout va très vite la
chaîne étant censée mettre fin janvier
2000 à peine un mois après la
promulgation de la loi qui l'a créé
d'abord on se demande ce qu'on peut y
mettre dans cette chaîne parce que en un
mois on a un mois pour la faire cette
chaîne quelques temps avant pierre
antoine jamet qui était le directeur de
cabinet de laurent fabius et me dit bien
bien voir on va te montrer les studios
on va te montrer là où ça se passera
hélas à ma grande stupeur me fait
descendre au premier sous-sol de
l'assemblée nationale
là où j'étais jamais allé et je découvre
un bureau dans le plus pur style
soviétique avec sur le bureau un micro
simple voilà et une chaise juste
derrière le bureau il me dit voilà c'est
là que ça va se passer
il se trouve que ce bureau était dédiée
au président de l'assemblée nationale en
cas de force majeure et là forcément je
me suis dit c'est pas gagné
paris
fabius respect total aucune consigne
la sole c je veux que tu démarres à
telle date et on n'a pas démarré à la
date geyter parce que je lui ai dit au
téléphone on n'arrivera pas à démarrer
avec une chaîne où les appareils ne
marche pas ne tourne pas parce que moi
je serai ridicule c'est pas grave mais
toi tu seras ridicule mais il a roulé
tout de suite
vous savez j'avais attendu pas mal je
voulais dire puisque c'est une idée que
j'avais eue dès ma première présidence
et quand les conditions étaient réunies
jeudi à ivan levaï
maintenant il faut y aller et vite donc
je suis arrivé est d'un seul coup je me
suis et je suis devenu chef d'entreprise
et donc j'ai recruté des jeunes y
compris des jeunes qui n'avaient jamais
parlé devant un micro et jamais mais qui
avait le goût de la j'allais dire de la
chose publique
moi j'étais journaliste politique à la
tribune donc sous les ordres du vent le
van est donc je suis arrivé dans les
bagages du vent le bail je n'avais
jamais fait de télévision
d'ailleurs bizarrement assez
paradoxalement comme une grande partie
de la toute première équipe qui est
arrivé dans cette chaîne c'est vrai que
c'était un peu fait de bric et de broc
au sens de des ressources humaines c'est
à dire que l'équipe qui s'est constitué
ben c'était pas c'était pas les
champions de la télé on était voilà il y
avait des gens qui avaient beaucoup de
passion pour la politique beaucoup de
connaissances du monde parlementaires
s'étaient pas contestable mais une télé
c'est une télé et donc j'étais
finalement un des seuls voire même à ce
moment là le seul je crois de mémoire à
venir de la télé forte d'une équipe de
12 personnes journalistes inclus
lcp s'apprête donc à prendre l'antenne
quand j'y repense c'est totalement
incroyable l'assemblée nationale nous a
octroyé écoutez bien un couloir une
table vie c'est dans ce couloir sur
lequel on avait aligné les bancs de
montage vent de montage qui étaient des
valises qu'on l'emmenait en reportage
c'était pas des bancs de montage
extrêmement perfectionnés donc ont été
alignés comme des sardines avec des
engueulades à n'en plus finir
parce que l'intel vous les mixer mélo
10ème et et wash est en train d'écrire
on a même eu un black à l'antenne à un
coupures dans le noir dans le noir un
problème de 2,2 probablement de raccords
électriques
ça vous verrez jamais sur une grande
chaîne nous on l'a fait
finalement le 21 mars 2000 à 8h30 la
chaîne parlementaire apparaît sur le
petit écran
bonjour et bienvenue sur la chaîne
parlementaire de l'assemblée nationale
pour le journal c'était comme tous les
premiers c'est plutôt réussi
parce qu'on y met toute tout notre coeur
et notre âme toute notre énergie on a
travaillé pendant une semaine dessus
c'est assez souvent le deuxième qu'elle
difficile où est le troisième moi
j'étais en régie finale le jour de la
naissance de lcp à faire le décompte
dix neuf huit sept six cinq quatre
partait on était vraiment un
l'aqua sous sous sous sous l'assemblée
la ici je vous parle nous sommes sous la
salle des quatre colonnes
les députés sont au dessus à un laitage
il descend d'un étage ils sont là donc
nous aurons j'allais dire le champ
le très chaud et même le brûlant pour
donner de la delà de la vie on avait
posé une caméra c'était un truc assez
incroyable sur la place de la concorde
qui donnait en fait sur l'assemblée et
je me rappelle de la chroniqueuse libé
qui était une dame qui avait la dent
très dure
quand elle faisait une critique et elle
dit vous savez au tout début des essais
pepsi comme ça quand on me prenait a été
accueillie lcpc vraiment une chaîne
formidable parce que c'est la seule
chaîne qui nous permet de savoir si la
concorde est embouteillée quand on veut
partir et traverser la seine
voilà ce qu'elle disait dès le cp êtes
sur la chaîne parlementaire de
l'assemblée nationale pour notre journal
de 13h dans le paysage audiovisuel
français lcp fait un peu figure d'ovni
loin de toute tentation sensationnaliste
la chaîne qui appartient entièrement à
l'assemblée nationale de trouver sa
place dans le paf sans avoir l'air d'une
réminiscence de l'eau et rtf tout en
respectant sa mission je voulais que la
chaîne parlementaire ne s'occupe que du
parlement et donc je voulais qu'on soit
dans le parlement
et j'ai dit à la première équipe vous
avez tous les députés qui représentent à
eux seuls toute la france donc votre
investigation elle est là mais comment
on pourra pas aller faire des réponses
des reportages on pourra pas aller voir
les députés chez eux au travail etc non
non c'est humain il voulait que la
chaîne parlementaire ressemble aux
autres télévisions
ah si j'étais poivre d'arvor quand je
passe un parlement non vous serez pas
poivre d'arvor à 6 g texte sert à
christine ockrent s'ést banon vous serez
pas vous ferez un nom ici 3
c'est parti tout l'équipe de public
sénat est heureuse de vous accueillir
sur cette nouvelle chaîne un mois plus
tard le 25 avril 2000 la seconde moitié
de pommes public senna rejoint l'antenne
qu'à l'époque seuls les abonnés du câble
et des bouquets satellites peuvent
recevoir un seul canal mais chacune sa
chambre ainsi commence en pleine
cohabitation politique
cette cohabitation cathodique entre deux
chaînes parlementaires dont la
crédibilité repose avant tout sur le nom
de ses dirigeants jean pierre elkabbach
et ivan levaï
[Musique]
il est 9h 14 à new york de bol un
kamikaze viennent de percuter les tours
du world trade center inimaginable
hallucinant a arpenté quotidiennement
les couloirs de l'assemblée nationale
arnaud ardoin apprend presque en même
temps qu hubert védrine et alain richard
les ministres des affaires étrangères et
de la défense
l'attentât du world trade center car
seront septembre il s'apprête à suivre
la commission de la défense qui va
auditionner françois léotard sur la
macédoine
c'est vrai que quand quand vous partez
sur ce type de deux commissions vous
n'avez pas le sentiment que vous avez
quand même faire un scoop
françois lyotard n'intéresse pas grand
monde la macédoine encore moins la
raison pour laquelle je suis l'amour à
15 heures ce jour là avec ma caméra
c'est parce qu on est dans un contexte
très particulier massoud a été assassiné
maastricht c'est pas n'importe qui c'est
celui qui évidemment s'est opposé aux
talibans est le moment où je tends mon
micro on ne sait pas encore si le
commandant massoud est mort là on sait
rien on veut des secours c'est pour ça
que le ministre répond je veux des
scoops évidemment personne comptons
quand les députés les ministres rentrer
dans la salle on ne se doute pas un seul
instant qu'elle est en train de se jouer
un drame planétaire qui va faire
basculer le monde
paul quilès vient d'apprendre la
tragédie l'audition est suspendu les
ministres s'éclipse pour rejoindre
matignon les députés découvre ces images
stupéfait
et amazon ya un silence de cathédrale je
suis en contrechamp parce que j'ai
besoin de voir leurs visages et en même
temps j'ai la curiosité moi même de
regarder cette télévision
donc je me décale légèrement
je me souviens très bien et je vois une
des tours jumelles qui s'effondrent
puisqu'à ce moment là la deuxième n'est
pas encore tombé à l'époque on va
diffuser je crois l'information il est
15h dans le journal de 19h30
on n'a pas d'autres espaces tout ça
paraît tellement loin c'est de la
préhistoire on n'a pas encore le site
internet qui permet de balancer sur
twitter on n'a pas les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui on pourrait diffuser
immédiatement c'est à dire qu à 15h02 je
pouvais déjà diffusé l'information le
ministre védrine ministre de la défense
ont quitté précipitamment le la
commission de défense là on aurait déjà
l'info quelques jours après l'attentât
arnaud ardoin part à new york avec
quelques députés et le président de la
république c'est la première fois qu'une
caméra d'elle cp sort de l'enceinte du
palais-bourbon
la chaîne parlementaire affronte le 11
septembre comme une grande
à peine un an et demi après sa création
mais elle n'a pas encore conquis le
grand public ni la totalité des députés
en novembre de la même année
certains d'entre eux réclament même sa
disparition dans l'hémicycle les députés
ont aussi discuté d'un amendement signé
par des membres de l'opposition visant à
supprimer les crédits alloués à la
chaîne parlementaire assemblée nationale
en a le plus craint d'ailleurs que cette
chaîne disparaissent aussi bel et bien
des parlementaires se sont intérêt à
interroger sur la nécessité de cette
chaîne qui coûtait oui c'est vrai
quelques millions d'euros en
l'occurrence 15 millions entre 15 et 16
millions d'euros fait 15 16 millions
d'euros c'est le journée c'est une
journée de fonctionnement de france
télévisions ceux qui ont eu l'occasion
d'intervenir sur la chaîne parlementaire
mondy à droite comme à gauche ne pas
avoir eu de retour
à la différence des interventions sur
d'autres chaînes ce qui traduit une
audience dont j'ai dit peut-être un peu
méchamment qu'elle était
vraisemblablement inférieur à ce qui
était celle de la mire au moment où elle
existait c'est à dire 0 5%
beaucoup de candidats pour la télévision
du futur de la télé numérique terrestre
pour recevoir la tnt
une bonne vieille antenne suffit le 31
mars 2005 le passage officiel de la
france à la télévision numérique
terrestre va rebattre les cartes entre
les acteurs de l'audiovisuel
nous venons de presser le bouton qui ait
symboliquement marque justement ce
basculement d'un numérique c'est à dire
18 chan 18 à 20 chaînes gratuites un
meilleur saut une meilleure image
je crois vraiment une nouvelle étape de
l'aventuré télévisuelle les élections de
2002 ont ramené la droite au pouvoir
ivan levaï quitte la direction de la
chaîne en 2003 tandis que jean louis
debré devient le nouveau président de
l'assemblée nationale la séance est
ouverte pour être crédible pour avoir de
l'audience j'ai décidé que l'assemblée
nationale allait payer pourrait sur la
tnt
mais à l'époque lci était dirigée par
deux personnages se le lait monsieur
mougeotte qui eux étaient opposés à la
tnt et qui ont fait des pressions inouïe
ils m'ont téléphoné et non deux fois
c'est scandaleux on fera on dénoncera ce
scandale vous dépenser de l'argent
public et on n'y croyait pas mais ça a
été le tournant et je suis persuadé que
si on n'avait pas forcé la chaîne
parlementaire alors on se regardait du
tout c'est un effort nécessaire
ou alors il fallait supprimer la chaîne
parlementaire
il
et pour fêter cette tnt je propose
maintenant de regarder ce film lcp sur
la tnt ça commence ce soir et ça
ressemble aussi à ça le vrai décollage
de la chaîne et pour la visibilité de la
chaîne c'est évidemment la mise en place
de la tnt parce que là on avait notre
place elle était acquise tue plus avant
tout à fait acceptable pour les as peur
et nous c'est la chaîne 13 voilà c'est
le canal 13 et là ça a été le déclic ça
a été le déclic parce que effectivement
le critère audience qui ne rentraient
pas en jeu au départ là nous venaient à
l'argument à un argument sérieux dès le
démarrage
pour moi c'était une défi un défi parce
que c'était une petite chaîne un petit
budget et puis il fallait faire de
grandes choses
mon idée c'était jour je voulais ouvrir
les portes de cette chaîne à tout le
monde aux grands aux documentaristes etc
à des journalistes en employait des
journalistes qui qui venaient y compris
des grandes chaînes de temps en temps
voilà il fallait vraiment dire faire
grandir cette chaîne on pouvait plus se
contenter simplement de mettre trois
personnes autour d'une table de poser
des questions et c'est donc fallait
sortir fallait aller voir la france
fallait aller voir le monde
il y avait une équipe de deux jeunes
journalistes passionnés et c'est moi
j'ai fait le choix de l'heure de
construire une espèce d'alchimie avec
des gens plus aguerris des figures de
l'audiovisuel bruno masure giesbert
pulvar john paul lepers etc etc
le contrat c'est le nom de cette
émission ce contrat c'est celui qui va
passer tous les mois
devant vous avec vous une personnalité
police assignait le retrait dès le cp
dans la cour des grands aussi enfin en
tout cas dans dans une cour a reconnu
donc envié par les professionnels par
les gens plus connu que nous qui d'un
coup avait envie de nous rejoindre pour
nous c'était super de passer de la
chaîne artisanale à la chaîne qui croise
à la cafétéria david pujadas
certes pas tous les jours mais de temps
en temps finalement
cette chaîne s'était construite comme
une espèce d'exception hélas elle
redevenait aussi une chaîne parmi les
autres électrochoc solidaire prise de
conscience salutaire
lorsque les députés s'immerge dans le
quotidien de leurs administrés le
résultat est à ne pas manquer on met en
place par exemple magazine sap et
j'aimerais vous y voir où on prend un
parlementaire et on lit mais rj dans la
vie de l'un de ses administrés il
devient facteur et devient un fermier va
etc
je lance ce truc-là tollé le député
pascal terrasse va devenir chauffeur vtc
je vais essayer cette vie en sachant que
je suis un très mauvais conducteurs il
voyait les ch'tis ou les marseillais où
les anges de la télé réalité sur lcp
évidemment ça n'avait rien à y faire et
j'explique je vous garantis que vous qui
évoqué les problèmes de l'agriculture à
l'assemblée nationale quand vous allez
allez passer trois jours dans une ferme
avec des agriculteurs vous en reviendrez
changé et c'est 75 une seule course
c'est évidemment un grand débat qui a
beaucoup agité ce qu'ils ont pensé lcp
est-ce que d'un côté on doit être une
chaîne très parlementaire très vertueuse
très sérieuse
1 et de l'autre côté une chaîne
dévergondée commercial non il fallait
simplement expliqué que cette matière
parlementaire ces discussions des lois
et c'est loin d'être quelque chose de
techniciens de grid os terre etc
c'était la vie quotidienne des français
et donc on se lance aussi dans une
conquête du grand public et pas dans une
logique d'audience dans une logique de
kalimat david avantages que une logique
de 10 bat mais qui fait le pari du sens
très vite j'ai pensé qu'il fallait avoir
une ligne éditoriale qui nous a menés à
piré traiter l'actualité parlementaire
bien sûr et aussi à événementialité tous
les grands dossiers politiques
myriam badaoui à vous
gestion très innocent sur le banc des
accusés reste maintenant à tirer les
leçons de ce fiasco judiciaire
après avoir défrayé la chronique pendant
plusieurs années
l' affaire d'outreau se termine en 2005
à paris par un acquittement général il
faut pas venir me dire à moi que la
firme trop est une erreur judiciaire
mesdames et messieurs monsieurbureau ne
s'est pas trompé dans cette affaire il a
écouté myriam badaoui web article
face à ce désastre judiciaire les
députés décident d'ouvrir une commission
d' enquête afin d'expliquer les causes
des dysfonctionnements de la justice
quand j'ai su que cette décision avait
été prise
puis aller immédiatement voir monsieur
vallini le président de la commission et
puis j'ai essayé de convaincre quelques
députés que je connaissais bien leur
dire écoutez il faut que cette
commission soit public soit transparente
parce que les français attendent des
explications sur ce fiasco judiciaire
et là faut dire la vérité la grande
majorité des députés était soucieux de
ne pas faire trop de bruit est donc une
manière un peu culotté je suis allé
trouver le président debré ça a été
pourtant que j'ai eue les levées de
boucliers de tout le monde mais on va
mettre en cause la justice m mais on va
mettre en cause un gendarme a peut-être
mais si nous ne sommes pas capables
d'entendre et pour désamorcer à scandale
il vaut mieux en parler que de le cacher
je considérais que il était essentiel
pour la communication du peuple français
à la suite du scandale d'outreau et bien
que pour tuer les rumeurs les non-dits
qu' on puisse faire
cet audit ses auditions en direct c'est
sans doute la première fois que la
représentation nationale reçoit
officiellement et collectivement des
acquitté dans une affaire judiciaire
l'assemblée nationale se devait de vous
exprimer son émotion face au drame
que vous avez vécu mais il nous incombe
aussi d'en tirer des leçons pour éviter
qu'un tel désastre ne se reproduise
pour la première fois lcp obtient
l'autorisation de filmer le travail
d'une commission parlementaire pour
retransmise en direct les auditions
menées par les députés vont avoir un
écho considérable
j'avais imaginé si nous pouvions
diffuser cette commission ça allait être
une sorte de feuilleton quotidien
pendant au moins 3 4 mois et ça a été le
cas monsieur fabrice burgaud je vais
donc vous demander maintenant de lever
la main droite et de dire je le jure je
le jure je vous remercie
la commission d' enquête a commencé je
crois le 10 janvier 2006 et s'est
terminée le 12 avril 2006 au bout d'une
semaine tous les journalistes toutes les
chaînes sont au 101 rue de l'université
nous on a une mais la mèche quelque part
qu'est ce qui me reste maintenant un
boulot de salariés et trois enfants
trois enfants d'autrui les 30 députés
qui composaient cette commission
denquête entendu plus de 220 personnes
ils se sont permis de bousculer les
experts judiciaires les psychiatres et
des psychologues et ça je dirais c'était
une que l'on dirait une initiative
politique j'irai noble vous avez été
entendu une demi-heure par le juge
s'améliore au bout d'une demi heure
j'étais parti en prison
eh ben j'ai rentré de 38 mois après qu
il était le bon dieu j'ai ressenti ça
comme ça ils avaient le droit de vie ou
de mort sur moi vous avez en charge la
république c'est vous et vous êtes
garant des libertés vous avez un rôle
très important
moi je trouvais que nous jouions un rôle
pédagogique intéressant parce que les
français connaissent les séries
policières américaines
ils connaissent comment la justice
américaine fonctionne ne connaissent pas
bien comment fonctionne du mois
maintenant ils le savent mais comment
fonctionnait la justice française
ça c'était aussi j'irai un autre enjeu
qui était à la fois politique mais
quitter aussi j'irai journalistiques ont
fait au total je crois deux cents heures
de direct sur la commission d' enquête
parlementaire d'outreau
évidemment personne ne
mais tout le monde passe à un moment sur
la chaîne pour pouvoir ça le résultat
des courses c'est une audience qui est
montée je ne sais plus mais on est
devenu une grande chaîne publique à ce
moment là en octobre de la même année un
second événement propulse de nouveaux
lcp sur le devant de la scène cette fois
en partenariat avec public sénat
les deux chaînes font alliance et
obtiennent la diffusion en exclusivité
des débats des primaires du parti
socialiste
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
cette soirée est une première dans
l'histoire politique de ce pays et c'est
une première pour la télévision un bon
jour richard michel qui est le président
de l'époque me dit voilà on a négocié
d'être la chaîne qui va diffuser le
débat pour les primaires du ps et bien
il va y avoir un présentateur pour au
public sénat ce serait ma nuque espère
qu'à comme infiniment plus de bouteilles
que moi et pour lcp j'aimerais bien que
ce soit toi bon donc en fait ce qui est
marrant c'est que on ne s'éteignent pas
habitués c'était pas du tout encore un
genre télévisuel donc je me suis pas dit
que c'était un truc énorme en fait
j'étais flatté j'étais contente je me
doutais bien qu'à voir en face de moi
laurent fabius dominique strauss-kahn
ségolène royal ça allait quand même être
pas complètement anodin ou secondaire
dans ma vie mais mais j'avais bon je
pense personne n'avait vraiment
conscience que c'était que c'était
vraiment un événement qui allait avoir
un verre aux tensions parce que ça
n'avait jamais existé en fait jamais en
france il ya eu des primaires
jamais c'est la première fois aux états
unis depuis longtemps mais en france
jamet et donc quand les autres médias
auront appris qu'on allait faire ce type
d'exercice complètement inédit à tout le
monde a rappliqué mais comme on avait
passé une exclusivité avec françois
hollande
et bien c'est nous qui avons eu
l'exclusivité
voilà pour l'instant les journalistes
sont encore en train de répéter les
questions qu'ils vont poser aux
candidats on les voit derrière moi avec
le réalisateur fib l'allemand arrive ce
ce premier soir du débat là quand même
toute la journée on avait senti la
tension monte et je crois qu'il y avait
un papier dans le monde je crois qu'il
ya vu un papier dans le parisien il y
avait évidemment jamais eu encore
vraiment papier consacré à nous comme ça
et en fait c'est assez tardivement je
crois que j'ai pris conscience que j ah
oui quand-même à laurent fabius bonsoir
bonsoir
ségolène royal bonsoir dominique strauss
kahn bonsoir bonsoir
alors ça ne vous a pas échappé le 16 ou
le 23 novembre prochain l'un d'entre
vous sera le candidat du parti
socialiste à la présidence de la
république
l'enjeu est donc de taille pour vous ce
soir les français vous regarde on avait
jean pierre elkabbach et richard michel
tous les deux dans l'oreillette mais on
a eu beaucoup plus jean pierre elkabbach
et pas pu s'en empêcher
enfin je pense quand il avait alors ils
avaient envie d'être à notre place donc
il y serait bienvenu à cuisiner ces
trois éléphants socialistes je vous ai
parlé des délocalisations alors ça se
calme et vous m'en parlera qu'aux gens
parlent très volontiers il vous reste 30
secondes pour nous parler des 35 comme
ségolène royal sinon on pourrait pas en
parler c'est là dessus je pense qu'il
faut qu'on revienne à ce qui était dit
au début et qui juste merci je me
souviens juste qu'à un moment il m'a dit
arrêté de sourire
alors je serai pas faire la webcam âge
et vous seriez trop vous avez un joli
sourire mais n'en abusez pas ça m'a
évidemment projets dans un désarroi
terry parce que je me disais bon que ça
veut dire c'est la chair d'une cruche à
l'antenne est en revanche je pense que
c'était aussi une manière de contrôler
mon émotion savent que sourire ça peut
être aussi une façon de sauver c'est la
fin de ce premier débat merci à vous
trois d'y avoir participé
j'ai toujours d'accord pour qu'on se
retrouve mardi prochain ségolène royal
mais on se retrouve bien mardi prochain
ce qui est pollué
pari gagné le débat de la primaire
socialiste rassemble 4 millions de
téléspectateurs
le succès du premier débat fait que le
lendemain toutes les chaînes tout le paf
nous tombe dessus nous appelle avions
fait beaucoup de jaloux les chaîne
d'actu vous avez pas le droit non c'est
nous qui devons le faire et c'est à
rester un deux puis c'est vraiment
devenu un genre télévisuel en soi et on
s'est tous habitués à voir le débat des
primaires à gauche à droite mais il faut
bien le dire qu'à l'époque c'est un
spectacle auquel les français ne sont
pas du tout habitués j'étais concerné
puisque j'étais un des candidats qui n'a
pas été retenu d'ailleurs le souvenir
que j'en garde c'est que c'était assez
formel quand même
chacun était des rations pupitres les
questions et être calibrée et mais
c'était d'une innovation importante ça
c'est sûr et donc la chaîne
parlementaire il a été hautement
associés ça a permis à lcp en fait de de
sortir du giron strictement
parlementaires et de se positionner
comme comme la chaîne de l'actualité
politique en fait au moment où je vous
apprends rien mais voilà il y avait la
concurrence croissante des chaînes
d'information alors à l'époque c'était
encore lci la la la la la la reine des
chaînes d'information mais il y avait
voilà la petite bfm tv qui grandissait
qui grandissait wells a permis vraiment
de de lcp de trouver une identité plus
plus riche plus dense et plus
intéressant merci de nous avoir suivis
bonne fin de soirée et a marre des
l'écho médiatique de ces deux événements
la commission d'outreau et les débats de
la primaire socialiste amplifié par
l'arrivée de la tnt permet à lcp de se
forger une image dans l'opinion publique
mais son évolution hors de l'hémicycle
pose aussi la question de sa véritable
identité
chacun son rôle la chaîne parlementaire
ce n'est pas une chaîne politique c'est
une chaîne qui explique la politique qui
fait comprendre les institutions de
l'état et qui fait aimer la politique et
l'état et l'assemblée nationale
tout dépend si vous mettez un petit pays
où un grand politique bon cela pas être
une chaîne politicienne en revanche il
ya un lien évident entre et dans les
deux sens entre parlement et vie
politique avec un grand p
puisque nous sommes dans une démocratie
parlementaire
donc je suis sûr que la chaîne doit
s'intéresser d'abord aux travaux du
parlement et des parlementaires dans
leur diversité
mais ce faisant elle doit donner une
certaine image la plus fidèle et la plus
élevée possible de
la vie politique avec un grand p la
réussite des débats organisés avec le ps
aurait pu encourager la fusion des deux
chaînes mais non jean pierre elkabbach
défend ardemment le périmètre de public
sénat que j'avais vu présent du sénat en
dix ans commençons par mutualiser les
moyens
puis je lui avais dit réunissons-nous
moi je suis pour une chaîne
parlementaire drame drame épouvantable
car président de la chaîne parlementaire
public sénat était une personnalité
importante il a simplement fait dire aux
sénateurs que si on veut se marier avec
l'assemblée nationale on ne parlerait
plus du sénat et nous n'avons pas pu
avancer très loin dans cette fusion
après la défaite de ségolène royal face
à nicolas sarkozy en 2007 c'est
finalement cinq ans plus tard et avec
françois hollande que le parti
socialiste revient au pouvoir
des qualités ce sont les mêmes droits
pour tous c'est le droit de pouvoir se
marier d'adopter tous les coups j'ai en
décide ainsi
tenant sa promesse de campagne le
nouveau président va provoquer un
véritable séisme dans l'hexagone une
différence de plus servir de prétexte à
des discriminations de temps c'est un
débat qui qui qui passionne la france on
en parle dans les dîners dans les
déjeuners de famille le dimanche matin
dans l'est dans les dîners en ville si
je puis dire
il ya des manifestations dans la rue il
ya des gens qui sont venus prier devant
l'assemblée nationale à genoux devant
l'assemblée nationale toute la société
est en mouvement autour tomba
s'intéresse en tout cas à cette loi et
la la la chaîne sur lequel on en parle
beaucoup on me donne tous les points de
vue on montre de dons que des
documentaires etc
c'est lcp l'impression de vivre un
moment historique dans l'hémicycle où le
vivez en direct sur lcp et sur lcp point
fr et vous êtes très nombreux
cet après midi en vous en remercie avec
le mariage pour tous
l'actualité s'est écrite à l'assemblée
et lcp est aux premières loges
le débat commence le 29 janvier 2013 et
va durer deux semaines non stop à la fin
d'un premier lecteur il est 5h40 du
matin à samedi matin vous imaginez il
était donc en en séance depuis la veille
et cctc incroyable koné débat marathon
une nouvelle fois les débats se sont
tournés vers la gestation pour autrui
plus que sur le mariage pour tous vous
êtes en train de créer un précédent
vous êtes en train d'assassiner des
enfants
il avait regardé le spectacle vous êtes
en train de donner je vais lever la
science
je vous préviens qui se passe est
véritablement des choses entre
christiane taubira kéké une véritable
oratrice et en face des longs et guaino
qui lui aussi est notre rapport avec vos
échanges d'arguments c'était c'était
passionnant et nous notre notre idée
c'était d'en diffuser le maximum à ces
français simple et digne qui ne demande
au fond qu'un peu de respect de
démocratie et de république
qu'allons nous répondre allons-nous leur
répondent seulement par ces deux mots
terride taisez vous mais il ya longtemps
qu'on n'avait pas entendu ça il ya
longtemps que les lumières ont imprégné
la réflexion philosophique scientifique
et puis vous vous êtes la zone est
encore la référence à la génération des
lois de mendel medel qui travaillaient
quand même sur les petits pois
comme vous le savez on partage le canal
avec public sénat est donc il fallait un
peu se battre pour pour obtenir qu'ils
nous donnent l'ailé des heures d'antenne
souvent ça s'est bien passé il ya
quelques fois il y avait un petit rage
et non nous en à notre journal à 22h30
on a nos émissions nos magazines et
quelquefois quand ils ne l'ont pas fait
on a eu des remontrances je me souviens
il ya le le président de la commission
des lois il revoit ce qui me dit comment
ça se fait comment ça se fait qu'elle cp
n'a pas diffusé à telle heure une heure
du matin les débats jeudi matin jérémy
public sénat diffuser ses propres
programmes
cependant lcpc trouver un autre canal de
diffusion
profitant de l'effervescence du pays la
chaîne se déploie sur les réseaux
sociaux et prend sa place dans le monde
du digital c'était le moment toute façon
tous les médias cim été paraît qu'on s'y
mettent aussi
et c'est vrai qu'on était ultra réactif
et qu'on donnait un peu le tempo par
rapport aux déclarations aux petits
phrases en transformant l'article 206
vous supprimez la belle-mère booth
supprimer un personnage essentiel de
leur théâtre est pour nous vraiment le
moment où on n'existait sur les réseaux
sociaux où on a été repris par les
autres par les autres médias par les
autres ont été repérées on devenait un
pourvoyeur d'information parlementaire
sur les réseaux sociaux et ça s'est fait
à ses goûts et c'est vrai qu'on a pris
ma place à ce moment là
l'assemblée nationale a adopté le projet
de loi ouvrant le mariage aux couples de
personnes de même sexe
on dit de l'assemblée que c'est le coeur
battant de la démocratie oui tout le je
crois que tous les démocrates le croit
mais quelque part parfois on oublie un
peu là on était voilà sur un sujet sur
un débat de société
les acteurs étaient bons les échanges
les débats étaient de bon niveau
c'était franchement tout à l'honneur du
parlement l'assemblée nationale c'est un
discrédite complet mais au discrédit il
ajoute le déshonneur à la même époque
mais dans un tout autre genre
l'assemblée nationale est le théâtre
d'une affaire politique qui va ébranler
le pouvoir et les députés la sphère
cahuzac
je n'ai pas monsieur le député je n'ai
jamais eu de compte à l'étranger ni
maintenant ni avant on est quand même
dans le dans le temple de la république
et on a un ministre ministre du budget
qui manquent sur son compte en suisse et
la siame en mentir à la représentation
nationale
est ce cet acte inqualifiable le parfum
de scandale est tel que les députés
décident de déclencher une commission
d'enquêté dont les audiences sont une
fois de plus retransmises en direct sur
lcp
les députés vont auditionner mediapart
évidemment qui a sorti la faire il faut
auditionner les ministres aficion
taubira pierre moscovici est en fait
l'histoire rocambolesque s'écrit jour
après jour dans ses auditions
c'est moi qui vous interrogeait le 5
décembre dans l'hémicycle vous avez
répondu à l'époque où n'aviez pas de
compte en suisse
c'est un mensonge qui a eu des
conséquences tout à fait considérable je
veux savoir si vous regrettez ce
mensonge du 5 décembre dernier
je vous ai menti en vous répondant
monsieur le député tout simplement parce
que dans les heures qui précédaient
j'avais menti au premier ministre et au
président de la république
on en a tiré un documentaire qui
décrypte l'histoire de sa genèse c'est à
dire depuis les révélations de médiapart
jusqu'au rapport final vous pensez
qu'une réponse est crédible qui consiste
à dire je me souviens plus d'une réunion
qui a eu lieu en janvier de cette année
c'est fait se lever cette amnésie vous
ne vous paraît pas crédible
ça veut dire que vous contestez les
propos de monsieur pierre qu'on se
trouve ici ça veut dire que nous n'avons
pas les mêmes souvenirs tu un peu
différente
le seul bénéfice qu'on a pu tirer de
cette affaire qui a fait beaucoup de mal
à la représentation parlementaire et à
l'idée que les français ont de la
politique c'est que à partir de la
sphère cahuzac le pouvoir politique a
commencé à réfléchir à la moralisation
de la vie de la vie publique
si aujourd'hui un ministre n'est pas
nommé sent qu'on est épluché son
patrimoine
c'est parce qu'il y a eu la ferc l'usac
mais une autre affaire va donner
l'occasion lcp de jouer un rôle bien
plus déterminant dans la transparence de
notre vie démocratique en diffusant un
documentaire qui va éclairer autant les
députés que leurs concitoyens inédit sur
lcp
que cache la vente d'une grande partie
d'alstom à l'américain general electric
le 19 novembre 2017 lcp diffusé pour la
première fois une enquête qui dévoile
les dessous de la vente du fleuron
industriel français alstom à l'américain
general electric
c'est le fil rouge de la journée rumeurs
de fusions acquisitions et le rachat
même rachat d'alstom par l'américain
general electric et les l'état qui
accepteraient que l'entreprise ait 2,95
1000 salariés dix-huit mille en france
soit vendue à la découpe en 72 heures
dans le dos du gouvernement
c'est une histoire particulière parce
que d'habitude on reçoit des dossiers
écrits papier on regarde on lit et là le
film était prémontées donc je reçois un
lien de visionnage à part david gendreau
et moi tout de suite je demande il n'y a
pas d'autres chaînes dessus parce que le
film était très bonne qualité avec des
animations c'était une enquête a poussé
et en fait il me dit non il n'y a aucune
chaîne et donc je regarde et je vous dis
ouais c'est assez c'est une petite bombe
le 4 novembre emmanuel macron abouti le
processus de vente
l'accord obtenu sur yvel tout autre les
co entreprises ne sont plus dirigés à
parts égales pire celle concernant le
nucléaire est largement sous contrôle de
general electric à plus de 80%
le documentaire n'épargne personne et
révèle la grande vulnérabilité de la
france face à la puissance économique
des états unis
le constat ici accablant que le film va
déclencher une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire
d'habitude celle inverse il ya une
commission denquête à l'assemblée on se
dit tiens ça pour être l'idée d'un film
on le suivraient dans un documentaire
là non plus des mensonges en soit cette
période sur la réalité c'est qu'on
entreprises ont présentation qui a été
faite de n'était pas exacte grâce à nous
le film c'est a fini de se produire on
lui apporte surtout une exposition
formidable le documentaire révélé
qu'aucune commission d' enquête n'avait
été ouverte après la vente d'alstom en
2014 malgré la demande d'un député
mais sa diffusion va relancer le
processus mois après la diffusion de ce
documentaire
olivier marleix qs députés les
républicains m'a demandé des contacts
notamment les contacts des deux
journalistes qui ont réalisé ce
documentaire et ça a été un élément
déterminant de sa commission d'enquêté
ça c'est une maladie des tables fierté
de l' affaire d'outreau à la sphère
kaiser en passant par le mariage pour
tous
lcp est à la pointe de l'actualité aux
premières loges quand elle se passe sur
son terrain à l'assemblée mais est-ce
bien sa place d'être le 7 janvier 2015
en duplex devant les locaux de charlie
hebdo on retrouve tout de suite jérémy
hartmann bonjour jérémy vous êtes devant
les locaux de charlie hebdo il ya eu des
débats sur chaîne d'info pas chaîne
d'info avec l'espèce du tropisme des
chaînes d'info en continu qui nous
faisait croire qu'on pouvait le faire
mais on ne pouvait pas le faire
donc tout ça était une gestation assez
lente de qui on est
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire objectivement
c'était pas si clair c'est une chaîne
d'information c'est une chaîne politique
c'est une chaîne parlementaire c'est une
chaîne de documentaires c'est c'est quoi
cette chaîne
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement en guise de réponses à ses
doutes existentiels lcp obtient une
preuve de sa légitimité en devenant 2010
est la seule chaîne à assurer la
traditionnelle retransmission des
questions au gouvernement que jusqu
alors elle partageait avec france 3
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans questions
d'actualité sur lcp nous sommes ensemble
jusqu'à 17h30 à 15 heures vous pourrez
suivre en direct et en exclusivité sur
notre antenne les questions au
gouvernement
il y avait quand même un paradoxe c'est
que la chaîne qui est dédié à
l'actualité parlementaire se voyait
privé du programme qui était le plus
emblématique du travail parlementaire
la démocratie c'est dans ce théâtre de
l'hémicycle qui est le théâtre ou la
démocratie serait transparente
un représentant du peuple peut dire
monsieur le ministre votre politique est
mauvaise je la critique
vous n'avez pas le droit de faire ça un
espace de liberté fantastique l'élégance
de votre question n'a d'égal que
l'inexactitude des propos que vous tenez
à la ministre l'euphémisation de votre
réponse ne cache pas la brutalité de
votre méthode
les avocats savent lire ils ont très
bien compris qu'il y avait une crainte
chez les députés que si on changeait de
l'a3 à lcp et beaucoup de gens qui cesse
de regarder les questions au
gouvernement quand je suis arrivé il y
avait la majorité puis l'opposition est
donc tout le jeu de la majorité
s'étaient durer le plus longtemps
possible pour qu'il n'y ait pas vos
transmissions à télévision de
l'opposition
il y avait quelque chose d'amusant à
l'assemblée nationale c'est un député
qui portait toujours des vestes de
couleur alors ils avaient des vestes de
couleur jaune est en fait ce député là
se déplacer au cours de la séance des
questions au gouvernement dans les
travées assez discrètement pour se
placer toujours derrière un député qui
allait poser une question mais souvent
on n'entendait pas savoir si vous voulez
il posé très peu de questions
j'avais même des spécialistes qui m'a
envoyé un petit mot disant citer mois-ci
témoin au site moi parce que vu à la tv
entendu à la télé ce important
après plus de 35 ans sur fr3 puis france
3 les questions gouvernement finissent
par déménager sur lcp en octobre 2010
est porté par ce programme emblématique
la chaîne se recentre sur sa mission
parlementaire et son identité premières
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
monsieur la salle vallier et
immédiatement retirer ce gilet parfait
monsieur la salle ce rappel au règlement
sera évidemment inscrits au procès
verbal et vous en subirez les
conséquences retirer s'il vous plaît ce
gilet la vidéo de jean lassalle
c'est une vidéo qui a dépassé le million
du le jour même notre chance c'est que
les des hommes et les femmes politiques
ont très vite aussi investir les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'ils ont voulu gagner en
visibilité mais c'est aussi parce que
c'était des dieux pour le meilleur et
pour le pire de débats de contradictions
d'interpellations
monsieur la salle s'il vous plaît allez
manifester hors de cet hémicycle
s'il vous plaît
la séance est suspendue notre mission
elle était toute trouvée parce qu'on
allait pouvoir accompagner ce mouvement
de fond des politiques des citoyens et
des citoyens vers les politiques mais
les réseaux sociaux sont aussi une agora
dans laquelle la classe politique est
fortement remise en cause en permettant
l'émergence du mouvement des gilet jaune
les réseaux sociaux mettent la chaîne
parlementaire tout comme le pouvoir
politique face à la crise de
représentativité que l'abstention
montant à chaque élection laissait
deviner risque emmanuel macron tente de
résoudre par l'organisation d'un grand
débat national
on est une chaîne de prise de parole
parce que c'est le propre de l'histoire
de l'assemblée a en réalité
donc même si ça a lieu à côté c'est un
instrument de revitalisation
démocratique et on doit nous la
compagnie émissions spéciales inédites
ce soir jusqu'à 22 heures nous allons
plonger ensemble au coeur du débat
national qui a démarré il ya à peu près
un mois dans tout le pays
il ya deux choses dans décisions qu'on
prend sur le grand débat c'est d'abord
de ne pas faire comme les chaînes info
donc nous on ne va pas sur les débats où
il ya président macro parce que ça c'est
un événement politique ça moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est précisément le fait
qu'on donne la parole aux français et
pas au président de la république
puisqu'il avait déjà à les y incite oui
bien bonjour à tous je voudrais vous
parler d'un problème problèmes de
pauvreté
allez-y n'ayez crainte vous êtes ému et
ben écoutez c'est pas grave que oui
deuxième élément c'est quand on fait
venir en plateau des gens autour du
mouvement des gilets jaunes on ne prend
que des élus des élus de petites
communes et que ça parce que la mission
des cp c'est aussi une mission de
promouvoir de soutenir la démocratie
représentative
il faut quand même organisé une société
il faut qu'il y ait des hommes et des
femmes qui représentent des idées on n'a
jamais vu une idée traverser cette
bibliothèque sur ses propres petites
jambes
c'est donc très très compliqué et les
médias là dedans
joue un rôle évidemment très important
pour moi le débat il sert à rien c'est
juste de l'enfumage pour moi je vous
souhaite à tous une bonne soirée je
retourne derrière
à voir nous sommes en guerre en guerre
sanitaire certes mais l'ennemi est là
invisible insaisissable qui progresse en
mars 2020 la chaîne parlementaire aurait
dû fêter ses 20 ans mais cette fois
l'actualité déborde du cadre
j'invite les orateurs à ne pas poser les
mains sur le flexible du micro celui ci
sera nettoyée après chaque usage par un
huissier
je vous indique enfin que l'hémicycle a
été désinfecté sera nettoyée avant et
après chaque séance pendant le
confinement c'était très particulier
parce que l'assemblée a été à un moment
un cluster il ya eu beaucoup de députés
qui ont attrapé le coc vide dans un
premier temps j'ai cru que j'allais
reprendre le signal caméra de
l'assemblée nationale des débats et puis
qu'il y aurait pas d'accompagnement
historial parce que j'étais je n'aurais
pas été en état de le faire et là il
faut le dire les la rédaction s'est
mobilisée à cause de l'épidémie de
coronavirus les députés ont mis fin à la
pause parlementaire prévue pendant les
municipales et rouvert l'assemblée
nationale pour une séance extraordinaire
moi j'étais aux premières loges parce
que je suis venu beaucoup beaucoup
assurer le suivi des travaux
parlementaires entre des questions
gouvernement qui vont avoir lieu toutes
les semaines pour le fameux contrôle du
parlement justement sur l'action du
gouvernement
des projets de lois qui vont se succéder
on parle de projet de loi d'urgence
sanitaire avec des restrictions de
liberté on parle de projet de loi de
finances qui engagent des sommes très
importantes les grands chiffres font
évidemment froid dans le dos doublons le
déficit de 91 milliards prévus au budget
initial et 115 % de dette
comment en est on arrivé là pour
répondre à la question que tout le monde
se pose dès la mi-juin une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire est mise en
place pour auditionner tous les
responsables politiques et acteurs
médicaux les auditions intégralement
retransmise par lcp sur les réseaux
sociaux tout essai qui comporte plus de
mille personnes est un essai qui cherche
à démontrer chose qui n'existe pas
vous assurer que je suis un très bon
mais on a eu des chiffres historiques
sur l'eau l'audition bien sûr du
professeur didier raoult et mais aussi
d'agnès besoins de tous les anciens
ministres de la santé xavier bertrand
marisol touraine
roselyne bachelot mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ce pays est infantilisé il
faut quand même un peu ce prendre en
main dans ce pays
c'est ça la leçon qu'il faut tirer se
prendre en main pour que la démocratie
fonctionne c'est peut-être aussi la
proposition de la chaîne parlementaire
qui au fil des nombreux défis médiatique
qu'elle a traversée n'a eu de cesse de
chercher un juste équilibre entre sa
mission parlementaire et la rencontre
des téléspectateurs pour être reconnue
d'utilité publique
tu crois qu'il est très important que
les électrices et les électeurs sachent
que leur député est actif soudan ait
encore à paris au bois qu'est ce qu'il
fait à paris il travaille
c'est en cela que la chaîne
parlementaire est importante elle montre
le travail du parlement et l'assemblée
nationale
et elles montrent que ce travail il
existe parce que votre député à
participer à une commission a élaboré
une proposition de loi
c'était très compliqué de faire une
chaîne de la matière et parlementaires
ni politique sans s'exposer au reproche
de privilégier un camp va l'autre
d'ailleurs c'est une des raisons qui
avaient empêché pendant des années des
années la création de la chaîne en
disait ça va être la chaîne de me suis
dit que la chaîne de monsieur grecque je
n'ai pas entendu ça et je n'entends pas
ça aujourd'hui est donc arrivé à traiter
la matière parlementaire et politique
d'une façon telle qu'il n'y ait pas de
reproche
deux des partisans ça c'est quand même
un accomplissement qui doit être signalé
mais au crédit de tous ceux qui ont fait
qui font cette chaîne
on n'a pas tous les jours 20 ans eh bien
oui la chaîne la chaîne a 20 ans et six
mois et c'est formidable
qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter à quand
on a 20 ans faire une brillante s'en
tenir
[Musique]